if we're going to make use of
chebychev's bound and other results that
depend on the variance we'll need some
methods for calculating various variance
in various circumstances so let's
develop that here a basic place to begin
is to ask about the indicator very about
indicator variables and their variance
remember I as an indicator variable
means that it's zero one value it's also
called a Bernoulli variable and if the
probability that it equals one is pay
that's also its expectation so we have
an indicator variable with expectation
of the indicator is pay and we're asking
what's its variance which my definition
is the expectation of I minus P squared
well this is one of these sort of almost
mechanical proofs that follows simply by
algebra and linearity of expectation but
let's walk through it step by step just
to reassure you that that's all that's
involved I would recommend against
really trying to memorize this because
it's I can never remember it anyway I
just reprove it every time I need it and
so let's see how the proof would go so
step one would be to expand this I minus
P squared algebraically so we're talking
about the expectation of I squared minus
two P I plus P squared now we can just
apply linearity of expectation and I get
the expectation of I squared minus two P
times the expectation of I plus P
squared of course the expectation of a
constant is the constant so when I take
expectation of P squared I get P squared
but now look at this I squared is zero
one value so in fact I squared is equal
to I and the expectation of I has now
appeared here that's P so this term
simplifies to expectation of I and this
term becomes two P times P plus P
squared of course that expectation of I
is a piece I got P minus two P squared
plus P squared the P Squared's cancel
and I get P minus P squared if you
factor out pay that's P times one minus
P or PQ which is the standard way that
you write the variance of an indicator
variable it's P times one minus P okay
that was easy and again completely
mechanical
there's a couple of other rules for
calculating variance from of new
variables from old ones that are basic
like a nativity of expectation but it
doesn't quite work so simply for
variance so the first rule is that if
you ask about the variance of a constant
times R plus B that turns out to be the
same as a squared times the variance of
biti of our the B doesn't additive B
doesn't matter and the because the
variance is really the expectation of
something squared when you get rid of
that constant a you're factoring out an
a squared and this is the rule that you
get here okay another basic rule that's
often convenient instead of working with
variance in the form of the expectation
of R minus mu squared is to say that
it's the expectation of R squared minus
the square of the expectation of R now
this expression the square of the
expectation of R comes up so often that
there's a shorthand for it words that
are writing parens you write e squared
Lavar it just means the same as
expectation of R squared and so much for
the second rule which we'll use all the
time because it's a convenient rule to
have I'm going to prove the second one
just begin to show you nothing to worry
about you don't even have to remember
how the proof goes because you can
reconstruct it every time so this it's
again simple proofs just by linearity of
expectation and doing the algebra so the
variance of R is by definition the
expectation of R minus mu squared let's
expand our minus mu squared it's the
expectation of R squared minus 2 mu R
plus mu squared now we apply linearity
to that I get the expectation of R
squared minus 2 mu expectation of R plus
the expectation of MU squared if I'm
really being completely mechanical about
linearity of expectation an expectation
of a constant mu squared is simply mu
squared and here I've got the
expectation off R that's mu again so I
wind up with the expectation of R
squared minus 2
mumu plus R squared the this is 2 mu
square minus 2 mu squared plus mu
squared it lines up with minus mu
squared and of course mu squared is the
expectation squared of our food the
formula again has claimed there's
nothing interesting here just algebra
and linearity of expectation and the
first result about factoring out in a
and squaring it follows from a similar
proof which I'm not going to include
here so let's look at the space station
Mir again which we used as an example of
calculating mean time to failure
so the hypothesis that we're making is
that with probability P the MIR space
station will run into some huge space
garbage and that will collaborate and
the probability of that happening in any
given hour is probability P so we know
that that means that the expected number
of hours for the MIR to fail is 1 over P
that's the mean time to failure and what
we're asking is what's the variance of F
if F is the number of hours to failure
what's variance of F well one way we can
do to just plug in the definition of
expectation and this will work the
probability that the that it takes K
hours to fail is we know the geometric
distribution the probability of not
failing for K minus 1 hours and failing
after that Q to the K minus 1 times P so
the variance of F using our previous
formula about the expectation of F
squared minus the expectation squared of
F this becomes a minus 101 over P
squared and we can forget about that we
want to focus on calculating the
expectation of F squared so F is 1 2 3
and so on that means F square is 1 4 9 K
square the point being that the only
value is that F squared can take our
squares so we don't have to worry about
counting them in in the sum that defines
the expectation so let's go look at that
so the expectation of F squared is the
sum over the possible value
that FK squared can take namely the sum
from k equals 1 to infinity of K squared
times the probability that f squared is
equal to K squared well of course the
probability that f squared is equal to K
squared is the same as the probability
that F equals K so I can and we know
what the probability of that F equals K
is it's a geometric distribution so the
probability that F equals K is Q to the
K minus 1 times P if i factor out a P
over Q this simplifies to the sum from k
equals 0 to infinity of K squared Q to
the K and this is a kind of sum that
we've seen before and that it has a
closed form and we could perfectly well
calculate then the expectation of F
squared by appealing to our generating
function information to get a closed
form for this and then remember to
subtract 1 minus P squared because the
variance is this term minus the square
of the expectation of F but let's go
another way and use the same technique
of total expectation that we used before
that is the expectation of F squared of
the failure x squared is equal by the
law of total probability so the
expectation of F squared given that F is
1 that is we fail after the on the first
step times the probability that we fail
on the first step plus the expectation
of F squared given that we don't fail on
the first step that F is greater than 1
times the probability that F is greater
than 1 now what's going to make this
manageable is that this expression the
expectation of F squared when F is
greater than 1 will turn out to be
something that we can easily convert
into a non conditional probability and
find a value for so the lemma that we're
using here is the following when I'm
thinking about mean time to failure if I
think of any function whatsoever G of
the mean time to failure and I'm
interested in the expectation of G of F
and I'm interested in the expectation of
G of F given that F is greater than n
that is it's already taken n steps to
get where I am then the thing about the
mean time to failure is that at any
moment
on what that you haven't failed you're
starting off in essentially the same
situation you were at the beginning in
waiting for the next failure to occur
and the probability of failing in one
more step is the same probability is the
same P and the probability of you're
failing in two more steps is QP and
three more steps is Q QP the only
difference is that the value of F has
been shifted by n it was in the ordinary
case we start off with F equals zero and
look at the probability that we failing
one more step two more steps now we're
starting off with F having the value F
plus N and asking about the probability
that it fails in the next step or the
next step on the next step so the
punchline is that the expectation of G
of F given that F is greater than n is
simply the expectation of G of F plus N
and I'm gonna let you meditate that and
not say any more about it but the
punchline is the corollary that the
expectation of F squared given that F is
greater than 1 is simply the expectation
of F plus 1 squared and that lets us go
back and simplify this expression that
we had from total expectation we now
have here's the F expectation of F
squared given that F is greater than 1
and let's look at these other terms this
is the expectation of F square given
that F equals 1 well the expectation of
F square given that F equals 1 is 1
squared because we know what F is and
that's the end of the story
times the probability that F equals 1
that's P the probability of failure on a
given step this is the probability that
F is greater than 1 which is Q that we
didn't fail on the first step and we
just figured out that this term is the
expectation of the square of F of F plus
1 so there's the 1 in the P and that
becomes a Q and this is the expectation
of F plus 1 squared now again I apply
limit linearity I'm going to expand F
plus 1 squared into F squared plus 2 F
plus 1 and then apply linearity of
expectation and I'm going to wind up
with the expectation of F squared
twice the expectation of F which
remember is twice over two over P plus 1
times the Q and now what I've got is a
simple arithmetic equation between the
expectation of F squared and some other
arithmetic and the expectation of F
squared it's easy to solve for the
expectation of F squared
and I'll spare you that elementary
simplification but the punchline is when
we also remember to subtract 1 over P
squared because that was the expectation
of the square of F of the expectation of
F we come up with this punchline formula
the variance of mean time to failure is
1 over the probability of failure on a
given step times 1 minus 1 over the
times the probability 1 over the
probability of a failure in the first
step minus 1 all right let's just for
practice and fun let's look at the space
station Mir again suppose that I tell
you that there's a 1 in 10,000 chance
that in any given hour the mirrors gonna
crash into some debris that's out there
in orbit so the expectation of F is 10
to the fourth about 10,000 hours and the
Sigma is gonna be the variance of of F
which is about one over one
ten-thousandth then is 10,000 times
10,000 minus one which is pretty close
to 10,000 squared for the variance and
then when I take the square root I get
back to 10,000 so Sigma is just a tad
less than than 10,000 it's 10 to the
fourth so with those numbers I can apply
the chebyshev theorem and conclude that
the probability that the near lasts more
than 4 times 10 to the 4th hours is less
than one chance in 4 and if we translate
that into years if it was really the
case that there was a 1 in 10,000 chance
of them--are being destroyed in any
given hour and the probability that it
lasts more than four point six years
before destructing is less than 1/4
so another rule for calculating variance
and then maybe the most important
general one is that variance is additive
that is the variance of a sum is the sum
of the variances but unlike expectation
where there's no other side condition
and it does not in any way depend on
independence it turns out that variance
is additive only if the variables being
added are pairwise independent now you
might wonder where the pairwise came
from and it's because variance is the
square of an expectation so when you
wind up multiplying out and doing the
algebra you're just getting quadratic
terms that you for variances of four
expectations of RI times RJ and so you
need to factor those into into
expectation of our x expect our I times
expectation of RJ which you only need
pairwise independence for so that's a
fast-talking through the algebra that
I'm going to leave to you it's in the
text and it's again one of these easy
proofs
you